it's been like a season and a half of
just boring stuff and it's been like two
movies of just boring stuff so i just
yeah i watched the movie in the cinema
as well and it was just like i heard it
was just a milk fest yeah i was just
nothing happened it was just like i felt
like i went in the loop well that's what
i hate about shonen movies in particular
right because like i
like demon slayer is like an exception
because that actually adapted the manga
right but to me shown in movies just
feel like very high budget filler
episodes where you watch the movie
pretty animation
that's why i don't watch anime movies
because they're just big fillers that
make money that's true but i'm glad to
see i i feel like demonstrate i finally
figured out how to make a [ __ ] ton of
money whilst also not pissing off tv
watchers just release the movie make
your billion dollars and then should be
like hey guys before the new season
starts here it all is in 20 chunk and 20
minute chunks that you can just watch i
thought that's great the thing the thing
about the movie i remember watching it i
remember thinking this just feels like a
tv show season yeah it just it literally
had points where i could feel where it
would cut off for an episode and then it
continued right the money of the movie
but then keep the tv style i mean so
many more seriously gonna start doing it
because of how yeah i mean i i guaran
[ __ ] tier tag on titan's going to do
it
i have a feeling i have this like right
way i am what do you think i have this
gut fight i don't think they will
think about the ending of attack on
titan is going to be a movie bold
prediction i think it's going to be
amazing
because because there's no way it would
be leaked because there's no way there
is no [ __ ] way right
like people in the industry saw how good
demon slayer did financially for the
industry and go we can do that again
attack on time your tin full hat on
there
attack on titan final final movie final
part one yeah i guarantee three i am go
i am going to bold prediction i don't
care if this ends up being like poorly h
material
that's all i care about i just don't
want to i'd like when i watch anime
movies i just want to know that i'm not
watching a filament
yeah
yeah like don't get me wrong
like don't get me wrong i've i've seen
like almost all the one piece movies and
they're fun but i'm not [ __ ] on the
edge of my seat waiting for the next one
yeah like you know what you're going
into with a show in anime movie yeah you
know what's going to happen yeah it's
going to be the the very bog standard
three-act structure where where you know
exactly what's going to happen and how
it's going to happen maybe there'll be a
slight twist but you know at the end of
the day it all gets resolved because the
plot needs to be resolved to move on it
can't be exciting it's just introduction
conflict resolution and then we end up
in the exactly the same place that we
started because it happens all the time
that's what sucks and that's why i have
no interest in like yeah thus they
continued on their quest that's how it
is do you think do you think that uh
chainsaw man getting released this year
is going to reach the same heights as
well
i would like
to i want to get that as a fan of the
manga i want this to be talked about
more yeah i have a feeling it definitely
has that potential now um i i it's been
a long time since i've seen
people hype up this one ip this much
yeah like i remember watching the
trailer and the trailer just like it
felt like the trailer just broke the
[ __ ] anime twitter for the day like
he got like a million views in a day on
twitter or something like less than a
day yeah yeah exactly which is like a
million likes like the actual tweet
that's crazy which is [ __ ] nuts for
an anime trailer it did not fall off did
not get rationed no it did not it
rationed every other anime
i just hope like the hype doesn't
collapse in on itself and everyone
starts watching it and people are just
like oh this wasn't as good as yeah
that's what i'm really scared of i
really hope maple like actually pulls
through with houses i don't see why we
have any reason to doubt man i don't
i'm praying i'm praying yeah that was uh
that was the anime talk of trash oh we
have a clear distinct like the
quarantine zone for anime no more anime
no no more anime for
even enough hot takes for one anime yeah
i mean i feel like i feel like there's
that's really like
from what i can see i mean
the only memorable things that people
are going to remember this season for
probably those shows yeah um and my
dress-up darling and that's pretty much
going to be it i think that's really
good
that's a good show
um i mean i've only seen like two
episodes it's it's a good show this is
what happens when there's kind of
rom-coms or uh not a slice of life but
kind of i mean
yeah i don't know how to describe it
that kind of genre of thing comes out it
always comes out everyone's like 10 out
of 10 10 out of 10.
everyone everyone hypes it the [ __ ] up
yeah they're like
and then like no one talks about it like
right after it's gone it's like it's
forgotten but like to this day there's
still like naruto naruto narrator right
like you know it never it's never gone
like i don't know why can you really
fault me for not watching anime
i don't know i i guess that's because
maybe the characters you can't speculate
as much about or whatever but like
naruto is like was a long-running series
that worked a lot of people are great
yeah well i rent a girlfriend
it's grandiose right it's great
[Laughter]
it's a rooting fall right
big moments big fighters big big pot
twists
all right ngr
it's got everything you can speculate
about on youtube i can't wait for season
two of rent a girlfriend um see i want
these videos where it's like uh you know
how like in those narrow to youtube
videos like what if thingy went against
thingy and then they speculate and it's
like what if the main protagonist and a
girlfriend went on tinder let's
speculate how well he would do
personally i think he would get a
success rate of 95 percent he'd be
slaying you know but that's just the
theory
that's just what i'm saying let me know
down below
i don't know
how did he make that
speculation honestly i mean i i believe
when rent a girlfriend season two comes
out that's going to be worth watching
because that arc is legitimately going
to be good is it is it going to cover
that chapter though no i should have
brought brenda girlfriend i should have
you know you're going to bring it up so
many times he's the most excited he's
been this entire episode you get so
happy though i'm just not i i can't hear
rent a girlfriend now without just
laughing
there's some real clown [ __ ] yeah if you
know you know i like it's like it's i
feel sorry for anime early watchers
because they're going to watch season 2
and they're going to think it's really
good because it it was a really good uh
it was a really good arc and they're not
going to know what's going what they
they'll never know what hit them they'll
never know what what's waiting for them
on the other side
um
but yeah i mean i just got done talking
about animation yeah stop talking about
anime now
everyone leaves where this this is